not only that I've been watching last of
us I'm also keeping up on the video game
oh are you gonna stream that video game
I don't know how to do that okay well
someday I also don't know how to put my
airpods on it so my wife just be waking
up with me going [__] well that like two
in the morning airpods don't make your
voice
yeah that was an interesting way do you
think airpods work well you think you
put on airpods and you'd be like oh my
bad I'm wearing airpods I thought you
couldn't hear me go [__] Hey listen guys
every once in a while you say some dumb
things right on a podcast right okay
that was a dumb one I'll give I'll give
you guys that that was pretty goddamn
dumb pretty goddamn yeah it was yeah it
was [__] you guys
[Laughter]
it's like the game is so loud it's just
screaming zombies and yeah yeah I love
the game I know you're trying to bail me
out yeah
I said some dumb [__] okay that was on
me that's my bad I do play the game and
I I do live in a house with my mom
no I I I've been playing this game I'm
obsessed I'm 39 years old and I'm
playing [__] video games again and
it's just like I'm so glad that I took
about
15 years up maybe 12 years off of video
games
I would not have accomplished anything
if I was playing video games or maybe
I'd be like a really big gamer but yeah
I would not I'm being dead serious I
love playing this video how happy would
you have been you know what I mean if
you had played every video again
you'd be pretty happy yeah
it's a phenomenal show did anybody
notice that the the most
made him not deaf anymore
or not didn't make him deaf but like the
way that he spoke in in uh he didn't
speak like a death when he was sick
do you know what I'm talking about no he
was just yeah oh you like when he
screeched after he became a yeah but he
didn't Screech like like he screeched
the exact same as the other people who
were infected but he also didn't hear
her initially because she had to like
tap him to get him to turn around and
attack her right yeah that's true but
when she when he flipped he didn't sound
like that he changed his voice yeah yes
it really takes over yeah isn't it great
that she was like asked his name when
his back was to her knowing full well
that she he can't understand a single
[__] thing that she has to say yeah
but deaf people can scream though
yeah they wouldn't know do they know
what it's like to scream that is a great
question I think so yeah there's a vocal
chords still work they just can't hear
that and sounds are saying so that they
don't know but they don't know what that
volume is they don't know the difference
between screaming and Whispering they
just know how to fix heat I think they
can feel about it but just emotionally
you're just happy you have the implies
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
I think I don't know I don't know have
you guys all caught up on the show yeah
yeah fantastic on the last episode so
good man and I thought like uh the way
they're kind of having her kind of you
see her kind of get jaded and it's kind
of sad like at the end when they bury
the bodies and she just like walks off
on it doesn't even really take it in you
feel bad and you also kind of see like
he feels bad that she's becoming as
jaded as him and I thought that was like
a really cool moment where he's like
it's almost like he's looking at his
daughter becoming something that he he
can't help her with but like he wishes
wasn't happening yeah because he's
trying to protect her from all over
becoming him yeah like life has made him
incredibly hard yeah and he doesn't want
to you know let people in he doesn't
want to develop his emotional
relationships with them because of you
know how painful losing his daughter is
and all of a sudden he's developing his
love for this little girl so it's like
having a daughter again but he's seeing
the daughter yeah become him of course
hardened by this reality it's got to be
heartbreaking yeah it's just brilliant
and playing the game the game is [__]
great did you like that they made him
deaf because in the game he's not does
not yeah but then they made that choice
I think one of the actors is the one
that made it did you think it added to
the story was the kid actually deaf yes
yeah he was so I think he's probably
only made the choice
yo
this today's not your day
yeah
it gets tough all day yeah I mean but
listen you just gotta you just say with
your chest go out there full confidence
sometimes you stick The Landing
sometimes you don't that was a game
though that's just all it is it was a
straight [__] like the sentence that
he just said [__] made a choice to
play Death like it was the biggest crack
of [__]
maybe he's the director I didn't make
the choice because uh yeah they had to
write lines for it
like they had to write the script around
a deaf person right yeah it was one of
the writers of The Producers yeah that
makes a lot more sense right yeah yeah
100 Choice yeah
so they've then hired a deaf kid yeah
yeah who also plays hockey great hockey
Trayvon Woodard yeah word he plays
hockey yeah oh he's nice
that's great guys it's taking too long
what uh this is too cold I thought we
would have taken it off he's not an
actor I thought he was actually great if
you like he's a kid yeah playing this
role but the older brother was
I think he stole the Toronto
huh did you did you sense Toronto
accident I didn't sense anything the
older brother did you not oh I'm not
sure I was just happy
annoying [__] who the fat [__] that
was leading oh yeah oh so happy she's so
annoying because that was like the most
unbelievable part just like damn
listening to her wait why why because
she's there like crying in her old
family house and [__] like that that's
not a leader yeah but she didn't do it
in front of everyone yeah still and also
they I thought it made sense that her
brother was the one that was like this
great man whatever trying to help and
then he gets killed and then she's just
angry and is killing everybody and leads
a revolt and they're like all right
we're with her her anger got us and
that's what that guy said basically your
anger got us more results than your
brother's love so wear with you and your
anger whatever your decision is even if
it's angry we rock with you